so as the post-game analysis is
operation desert burp continues we
realized that for Trump's critics peace
means defeat I mean if you listen to the
media right now it's like we killed lady
die or Elvis when Princess Diana died
for example there was a huge emotional
outpouring these kinds of Elvis Presley
in our culture it turns out that this
generally killed was a beloved hero of
the Iranian people to the point we look
at the people who got pictures up now
these enormous crowds coming out there's
no American emotion in this case for
there's a hell of a lot of emotion on
the other side I'm almost impressed by
his stupidity Chris you've been around
Iran can form a crowd over a sneeze and
they'll shout death to America over
anything including when HBO canceled Sex
in the City and that idea that killing
bad guys makes them martyrs
I guess we better not kill any bad guys
then with that logic we should have
stayed out of World War two left bin
Laden and al Baghdadi alone and free
everyone from death row but in the
media's world Trump is Hitler and a
terrorist is Martin Luther King yeah New
York Times hack actually compared
salamati to him what you're describing
feels like the kind of unified national
outpouring that is reserved for a small
handful of figures in any country right
I mean a beloved president a civil
rights that are like Martin Luther King
what an ass but Trump once again has
driven critics to defend the
indefensible remember when they've asked
Trump for being mean to ms-13 now he's
got the view applauding white racist
because they agree with the view what's
some good news this is a tiny thing that
I noticed you remember Richard Spencer
he's basically the organizer of unite
the right when it said the white
nationalist group that was marching in
Charlottesville it's all in for Trump
not anymore
his his quote he tweeted last night I
deeply regret voting for and promoting
Donald Trump in 2016 oh my gosh
Wow she almost said that's good news and
then she caught herself but as the idiot
squawk trump rolls on handing out great
ideas like gift baskets I spoke to
Secretary General yesterday and we had a
great conversation he was very I think
he was actually excited by it
and I actually had a name Nate oh right
and then you have Emmy middle-east
yo card they told me I said what a
beautiful name they tell me I'm good at
names that is we don't deserve him
meanwhile mayor Pete tweets that maybe
we should share the blame for that
downed plane even though it was Iran who
did the shooting and that guy is running
for president so Trump once again foils
his critics not just by being right but
letting them be so wrong check out this
CNN interview the American government
the American president made a serious
miscalculation
they made a serious mistake by
assassinating by taking this terrorist
action against commander soleimani
and I'm sure that they regret what
they've done
does that lady look familiar to you you
centered the press conference the other
day you said yourself that if there was
an attack on this embassy that you would
destroy the hostages could you really do
that yes we mean it could you personally
lift up a gun put it to the head of one
of these people and kill him yes when
I've seen a gun being lift up an
American machine gun being lift up and
killing my sisters and brothers in the
streets of course oppression and tyranny
must be destroyed you know I'm thinking
maybe don't get an opinion on America
from someone who threatened to kill
American hostages but I guess the
network's got to find one person outside
their own news room who's mad that Sal
Imani is dead and that's hard because
that one person Salah Monty is dead so
Martha I want to go to you first about
the plane we're learning that it was
probably or likely shot down by Iran
would you a Buddha
tweeting and I think we have the tweet
that you know it's as tit-for-tat
between military powers that led to this
essentially spreading the blame I mean
the suggestion that there's blame from
the United States or from this decision
by President Trump for the hundred and
seventy-six individuals who perished in
this plane crash I think is is really a
remarkable remarkable statement on
behalf of someone who's running for
president of the United States to not
understand that this missile from what
we're learning was sent up by Iranians
it was Russian made it was aimed in
their own effort to retaliate which they
said they wanted to do but to not go a
step further back to talk about the
killing of an American contractor to
talk about the overrun or the attention
overrun of a US Embassy sovereign
territory in in Iraq that was built by
the United States I just think it's I
think it's an irresponsible statement by
a presidential candidate yeah I don't
think that helped him Lawrence what do
you make of a War Powers Act that
they're voting on yeah I think it's a
complicated matter but I think there's
two camps Mike Lee is saying look I went
in there yesterday to question the
generals and the briefers about not the
attack but authorization when do you
think you need to come back to Congress
to declare war he agrees with the the
killing of Solomonic he believed that
the president has power as a matter of
fact if you don't believe believe it go
back to the documents that Congress
signed back in 2002 that gave the
president the call to make this happen
and he only has to notify them before or
he has 48 hours to notify Congress then
so that is a wash we don't even have to
debate this what Mike Lee is saying is
that there has been moments where the
intelligence community has to mislead
there's been moments where the military
is misled we just saw reports on
Afghanistan and we need to know all of
the raw intelligence before we decide to
go to war and Congress does have the
right to do that but Democrats are using
Mike Lee to say the president should
have never killed Saleh money and that's
not what he's saying well and the
resolution specifically that the house
is working is really non-binding more of
a statement than anything that the
president is going to be beholden to but
I want to go back to the media for a
minute and Democrats and Pete Budaj
they're making this false moral
equivalency between
the Iranian regime and President Donald
Trump aka America and what we're doing
to protect Americans in the Middle East
for him to say that we had just as much
responsibility for this plane shoot down
as the Iranians did completely unlimited
any kind of responsibility for them they
are hiding the black boxes they don't
want us to find out what happened and
also it's really interesting to see the
media constantly say that the president
is a bigot the president is anti-gay the
president is this or now they are openly
defending and equating people like
Soleimani to someone like Martin Luther
King jr. or princess died when they
stone women they hang gays off of cranes
and just justified it just the other day
they kill innocent protesters in the
streets for daring to speak out and not
show up just alimonies funeral so they
need to pick a side here
you can't just be against this kind of
behavior when you think it's coming from
President Trump which it never is and
then turn around and defend something
like the Iranian regime they don't
always run out of time this is a stupid
war Ward and the president's friends
have to have the guts to tell him
killing sulemani at this time was a
terrible idea as I told Martha as I said
to Martha the other day a terrible idea
brilliantly executed why now what does
America win why why are we why are we I
mean why are we picking this fight for
what General Grant they could the
General Patton would give General
Petraeus we assassinated him in it there
for what why did we do that exactly
what did we do that certainly am acting
killers not guilty Americans America
listen I got news for you there they say
he killed 600 Americans the last time I
counted there were 600,000 Iraqis who've
been killed I'm sick of this war me mm
worried for false pretences and now
we're picking a fight with the other
people with the wrong whatever allergy
eyes get this far although you can
you're conflating two things I agree
with you about the Iraq war and I'm
hoping that this is a direction that
Janice tan yeah at what point do we say
enough put the journalist stop eating in
the bed I agree with you on that but
this is different this is not about work
you're in a prison of two ideas war no
war no this was an executive action to
take out somebody that's been killing
Americans it's already retaliated the
started one with they killed or the
militia killed an American contractor
wounded several others what is that's on
there at the 27th of December more or
less any attack on American policy on
the way you're missing something you're
as the media has been doing you're
missing a key thing that happened they
killed the American contractor wounded
the others we had a massive retaliation
against the same militia
in Syria and in Iraq we killed 25 Iraqis
so we shall we learned before we have
weeks they killed the contract that we
killed 25 Iraqis then they had the the
the demonstration in the uprising the
cease the siege of the embassy this is
action reaction he ordered we took a
rocket off the head of the snake of the
largest terrorist in the world no you're
right
but that's that's the Middle East right
now is you kill somebody bad a new one
comes along but we killed somebody